Let's have a closer look at constructing objects. This time we'll use a
different class. The class called rectangle. In BlueJ I right-click on the
class in order to construct objects. Now look closely here. Up here I have two
lines that start with the keyword new. Followed by the name of the class. The
keyword new is an instruction to make a new object of the class that's written
after new. Inside the parenthesis, we put the construction arguments. Now
notice that the're actually two of these. Two so called constructors. The first
one wants four construction arguments. The second one doesn't want any. Let's
use the first one. Here we see the construction arguments described as x, y,
width and the height. I'm filling in some values, five, ten, 60 and 90 and when
I click OK, the familiar object icon appears. Now as always in BlueJ, I can
right click on the object icon to find out what methods there are. For example,
the get width method gives me the width and that's the 60 that I just supplied.
You might be a little disappointed that the rectangle is not displayed but to
display, simply call it straw method. Right-click Draw and here it is in a
little window. Let's look at the second constructor, the one with no argument.
When I select it, I don't need to supply any argument values and the object is
constructed. What rectangle might it be? I can draw it. But nothing seems to
show up. Let's investigate. it has width zero. And height zero, not a very
useful rectangle but of course I can always grow it. And there it is. At any
rate you have now seen that the rectangle class has two ways of constructing
objects. One constructure take four arguments, the other none. Let's have a
look at it's Javadoc.